perfect beer what a concept while the
basic ingredients of beer haven't
changed much since ancient Egyptian
times most modern beers go through seven
essential process sites the mill the
mash mixer the lauter tun the brew
kettle the fermenter the aging tank and
the finishing tank
steam whistle has three teams of brewers
working eight-hour shifts head brewer
jeff and brewer Elizabeth call
themselves the HOS draggers because they
make sure the beer never stops flowing
and they help Marek keep tabs on each
batch of beer at every step of the
process
most beer is made from malted barley
malted barley what's that about
the barley kernels are usually soaked in
water for three days so they'll
germinate which is then halted by dry
roasting at that very specific point the
barley is just the right amount of
moisture and the right amount of protein
and must be no smaller than two and a
half millimeters pretty particular
requirements only very large breweries
malt their own barley most receive it
already malted milling the malt is the
first step in the brewing process in the
mill the malted barley grains are
cracked cracking the outer shell of the
malt helps release the starch from
inside the grain Jeff Pearson will make
sure the crack malt is mixed properly in
the next step the mash mixer
this is where we introduced the dry
grain did a very wet water and what
happens is it it goes in and form so it
looks like a porridge
hot-water reactivates the natural
enzymes in the cracked malt forcing the
starch to convert into sugars which
dissolve into the water the brew then
goes to the third step the lauder tongue
in the lauter tun which is similar to a
colander the mash is strained and a
clear sugary liquid called work drips
into the bottom of the tank
during this stage the Brewer adjusts the
strength of the mash he calls it
sparging
essentially what we're doing was just
eluding so what would it be like is like
say you use twice as much coffee and
your coffee maker to make coffee and
then you're adding water to it glued it
down so it's like drinkable the next
step in the process is the brew kettle
which is similar to a pressure cooker
here the work is carefully brought to a
steaming boil and at the exact moment
the recipe requires the brewmaster adds
flavor giving hops sometimes at
different stages compressed into pellets
hops don't look like much but they're
the stars of the beer recipe hops are
just like spice they're like the spice
of the beer after boiling the brew is
cooled and moved to the fermenter tank
where the alcohol will be produced here
yeast is introduced to the cooled work
by now the work is about 10% sugar the
yeast literally eats the wort sugars and
as it does it produces alcohol and
carbon dioxide
yeast is a little organism little Pacman
that goes in there and eats all the
sugar and it burps out the carbon
dioxide and it creates the alcohol that
makes a delicious beer